today there would be a corridor video
with a behind-the-scenes to go with it
there is not let me wet up wipe all this
Pizza grease off my face here so I can
talk to the Internet and a delayed game
that's good is still good forever but if
you rush a game and it's bad you know
it's bad for ever we had a lot of issues
I pulled an all-nighter on Saturday
trying to get this video done it's not
done Carmichael was working all day
today trying to get the BTS and Samba
signed done for a number of reasons the
video ended up having to be delayed till
probably Wednesday wave Wednesday is
gonna be when the BTS does up one is the
nerf rotation I don't know when the next
time Anika video is about to go up but
don't worry we know that you guys
understand but at the same time we
struggle to get you guys new content
every other day and new corridor videos
every other week but sometimes when
you're doing a concept that no one's
ever done before you run into issues
that are unforeseen it is currently
10:00 p.m. on Sunday night the day
before the videos supposed to go up cuz
this video got delayed Carmack was like
man a video has to go up he has never
missed a video since the vlog started
120 vlogs ago
if you truly enjoy this channel and
enjoy the content on this channel you'll
accept this
[Music]
needless to say
whoa that's zoomed hello CI needless to
say there's a there's awesome content
coming soon normally there's one going
up today you're probably going to say
hey you're making way more of a deal
than it actually should be hopefully
you're correct I'm going on